peu
[Musique]
dynastie des ebooks la princesse nadine
ebook est en espagne amoureuse du beau
toréador lopez dit lolo mais tout le
monde ne la fait pas à bras ouverts
c'est une affiche du diamant tout briser
mon coeur et assure qu'elle a beaucoup
changé ma qu'elle a changé complètement
de look elle s'est transformée peu
victime de croire à l'abri des courses
et le perdriel
elle fait la russie exactement comme toi
répit comme tous les tickets côtoiera
construit par l'union
ce sera très mal aux mamans et hachoud
madrid et vios mes gars comme elle a
changé sa démarche malgré les gardes et
là on dirait tout simplement la vie
mignot toujours très mal
salut berges marque fait que je sois
toujours riches toujours belle toujours
amoureuse de man le lot fait que la
vieille halle crève très vite parce que
mon lolo russie sa corrida
merci
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
oui
elle
[Musique]
n'oublie pas de me ramener la culée deux
oreilles le mât dans le pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]